hey this is Peter Rubin from wired we're
actually here on stage at the Iron Man 3
display on the show floor at comic-con
Marvel was kind enough to let us up here
because for next year's Iron Man 3
they've got the suit which you can see
over my shoulder from the upcoming movie
but then behind at the back of the stage
they've got the entire chronology of the
suits that Tony Stark created in the
movies from the original prototype in
the first Iron Man movie all the way
through to the variations and to Iron
Man 2 but then of course this is the
payoff right here Shane Black is behind
the lenses time around so we're going to
keep you updated on more Iron Man 3 news
as we get it so stay tuned wire comm for
more Comic Con goodness